all right in this month's so vegas
segment i show you how life is beautiful
festival helps keep downtown las vegas
one of the world's
greatest campuses check it out
since 2013 life is beautiful has left
its mark on downtown las vegas
the music culinary and comedy components
of the festival last only three days but
the art stays on the walls and in the
streets and we also hope to be able to
utilize these and other events you know
midway that we can keep the art program
going with las vegas and life is
beautiful connected organizers invite
renowned artists to paint the town but
this year they decided it was time for
more local love my wife and i have
worked for the festival since the
beginning and then we had the
opportunity to curate the local program
this year and really
put some light on our las vegas local
artists
so we were able to select 11 different
artists for
installation murals live paintings
that you'll be able to catch around the
festival this weekend like local artist
travis jackson whose work you can find
at level up arcade the velveteen rabbit
park mgm omegamar inside area 15 and now
for the very first time at life is
beautiful first time
at lib
getting to show off some pretty colors
and line work and what is he bringing to
the life is beautiful canvas a parallel
world if you will
where frequency and and wavelength
dominate uh
waking reality clearly interpreting the
festival art can get deep but how the
curators choose who to feature is simple
we both are just such art nerds and we
love
spending the time like researching that
so a lot of it came down to personal
choice and
it's been great because we've ended up
making such great friends with these
people as well and realizing like las
vegas has a wealth of great artists who
are amazing people beyond being the
party and now sports town vegas is an
art town too the downtown area is
probably one of the more well maintained
open air museums in the country
and it's because of the teams that work
hard to maintain them
to put them up
and then you know the world
world-renowned artist that we have that
mixes in with our local art and it's
it's really fun to see them like
seamlessly connect and and co-exist
together you know i was stoked that they
invited me to come over and make this
beautiful art here
very happy to be here 3d illusion and
anamorphic street artist leon kear
traveled all the way from the
netherlands to build his crypto casino
right on ogden between 7th and 8th
street you see the slot machine it is
called the crypto casino and of course i
don't want to take the fun out of it of
the game but i also want to emphasize
the
kind of story behind it that you have to
be
careful of what you're doing while
playing the game now leon wants you to
get the message and the photo it's all
about angles with his work and you will
always see that with my work so you see
there people standing yeah more down
more down with your hand or go up go up
more to the left more to the right so
that's that's a fun piece yeah and to
explore more fun pieces life is
beautiful also makes life easy as you're
traveling through the festival from
stage to stage from food truck to bar
it's filled with art and it's really
interactive like you can go right up and
touch it everyone can take great
photographs with it life is beautiful
actually has an app that you can
download on your phone and
through that app there's a map
there's a schedule you can actually
customize your own schedule so if you
wanted to see a certain artist
at a certain time or a musical art act
you know you can just put it in your
schedule your phone will notify you um
so it's a life is beautiful has just you
know gone above and beyond to enhance
your experience and your imagination
day one baby today the three i feel like
i can just reach in and pull that out
you have to go see that it's you can do
the lever picture yeah it's just it's
incredible amazing here from the
netherlands cool stuff starts today
first time in downtown las vegas that's
amazing yeah he loves it